[Music]
good afternoon everyone
welcome to today's event next gen
architects and researchers
applying new methods and tools to the
making of future high density liveable
cities
this webinar is the second in
conjunction with the
dense plus green cities exhibition that
was shown at the national design center
from march to july 2020 and highlights
the cutting edge methods and tools
that the next generation of researchers
and designers
apply to inform the design of future
high-density livable cities
this event is organized by the sutd
advanced architecture laboratory
and the design singapore council and
supported by the national design center
this event is also part of the national
design center's next
gen program lineup for october 2020.
my name is anjana devi srikad i'm a
researcher at the sutd advanced
architecture laboratory
and i will be your mc for today today's
session
explores some tools and methodologies to
derive new planning and design
strategies
for high density and livable cities that
acknowledge their scale and the
complexity of the urban systems
with the help of new tools and methods
it is possible to gain insights from
everyday activities
on streets and public spaces one of the
tools that helps us decipher the
complexity of cities better is network
science
simply put it helps us understand our
streets public and commercial spaces in
a larger scale
how connected they are how easy it is to
get from any point on the network to any
other
how probable you are to take a
particular route to work every day
and to understand the optimal allocation
of public and commercial spaces
with the help of computational tools it
is possible to derive information from a
vast amount of data about streets
this enables decision makers to optimize
design strategies for accessible public
spaces
better streets and efficient transport
systems
with this i would like to introduce our
speakers for today sri lanka
paula krishnan and ajay kumar manual
and sergey who will elaborate on spatial
network analysis
some of its technical aspects
and its implications on design and
planning
in architecture and sustainable design
at sdg server
her ongoing design ongoing doctoral
research interest
focuses on the increased benefits of
integrated landscape design
on high density urban environments and
the development of strategies towards an
evidence-based design practice for
sustainable and resilient urban design
solutions
i'd also like to introduce our other
speaker for today ajay kumar
ajay graduated in 2016 with a master's
degree
in aerospace engineering from ntu
singapore and tum germany
with a specialization in urban science
ajay's doctoral work is focused on
emergent mobility patterns in vertical
cities
sri anaji over to you
thank you anjana uh
thank you for uh the introductions um
and also for setting the context for the
presentation
uh let me start by thanking design
singapore
and the national design center for
giving us a platform to share our
ongoing research work with all of you
today our presentation um we'll be
discussing mainly three questions
why is it significant to explore new
research methods
and tools to understand the design
of future high density livable cities
how can we use these new methods
that are available today for our
objectives and finally
what are we expecting to contribute for
the future planning
and design of cities so let me start
with the overview of why we need the why
we need to explore the new methods
but 70 percent of the world population
expected to live
in urban areas in the next 30 years
future cities are going to be
characterized by high densities
more complexity in terms of multiple
interconnected systems
and verticality as there would be a need
to keep the
built footprint compact sustainable and
resilient
thus future cities we will be living are
going to go
dense and they're going to be vertical
now in addition to these two components
another third element
is going to be green so integrating
intensive greenery within the urban
environments have proven to be
critical factor in transforming these
dense
and vertical concrete jungles into high
quality
livable cities so in cities like
singapore
public and common spaces and networks on
ground
are increasingly complemented with such
spaces and networks on elevated levels
in the form of sky bridges sky parks sky
gardens
and roof gardens now combinations of
these often applied
to mixes of residential commercial civic
institutional programs combine at times
to produce
vertical cities where such spaces become
components of a larger urban system and
networks
so the dimension of verticality presents
possibilities
to generate dynamic urban forms and
utilize cutting-edge technologies
to provide new insights into addressing
the environmental issues
of climate change and urbanization
by challenging conventional notions of
urbanism
it offers new possibilities towards
reimagining cities
and creating sustainable resilient
adaptive
and responsive livable environments for
the future
as you see this imagery which was
created in 2011 by hoha
as its vision for a future vertical city
we're not very far
from this vision to becoming reality
so having established the need
to explore new methods let's see
how can we do what we are intending to
do
now often as a designer a landscape
architect i wondered
how some spaces we design become highly
successful and well used
and become an integral part of urban
life
while some spaces do not exhibit the
same quality
of integration in terms of its social
and spatial performance
so what makes some design spaces more
integrated to the larger urban network
while the others equally well designed
spaces
fall short of expectations so these
questions become more significant as
spaces need to be socially
spatially and economically sustainable
so as cities get compact systems get
multi-layered and spaces get
interconnected
at horizontal and vertical planes there
is a need to understand
the complex interactions of extensions
of the public and common green spaces
into the vertical dimension with those
on the ground
their impacts on the patterns of human
movements and social interactions
their contributions to a more livable
high density urban environment
and more significantly the scalability
of these urban elements
for their effective performance so
traditionally
design and planning approach has been
guided by our instincts or intuitions
by our past project experiences and a
tried and tested method approach
what we need to do is to layer them with
an evidence-based integrated design
approach to create socially sustainable
spaces
that can also respond to various
programming
now gathering evidence has also
traditionally been limited to user
surveys
visual observations past studies and
guidelines
but with the advent of technology and
access to a vast range of devices
new accurate methods can be applied to
collect user data
so this would provide a dynamic feedback
loop and enable scenario modeling for
assessing spatial performance
thus what we need is a systematic and
integrated approach towards creating
physical visual and social continuity
from the ground level horizontal ability
to its vertical urban extensions
in a recently completed study on dense
and green building typologies by the
singapore etf center future cities
laboratory
there were with the integrated vertical
developments were systematically
analyzed
for their larger urban impacts and the
study successfully concluded that these
new integrated typologies become an
integral part of the larger urban
ecosystem
and are also very effective in providing
the ecosystem services
more importantly the benefits can
significantly multiply
with its effective social and spatial
connectivity
with the larger urban network thus
understanding the interconnectivity of
the spatial
and social behaviors is imperative
towards planning future urban
environments
now urban network studies have been
carried
out for many decades now to understand
spaces from the way people move through
them
academics architects planners and
designers have widely used the tools and
concepts of space syntax
to understand the configurations of
spatial layouts and the relationship
between the spaces
a wide range of tools have been
developed and explored
and they have been pretty effective in
understanding build spatial networks
complexity science with its evolutionary
approach
looks at networks as a generic system of
nodes
and edges that constantly change
and evolve with an underlying structure
that has a pattern and that can be
generative so with cities becoming more
complex and urban systems becoming
multi-layered and interconnected
application of complexity science in
understanding cities
and urban systems is slowly gaining
momentum
thus the application of complexity
science methods present a new scientific
approach
for designing and planning future cities
i would not take the opportunity to hand
over the presentation to ajay who will
give us more
insights on how this approach becomes an
immense potential
for future architects and designers over
to you aj
thank you straight yep
as we mentioned that the contemporary
urban design is actually primarily
defined
by intuition and heuristic methods
so every year more people move to urban
areas
in record scale and cities have grown
dense and vertical
to accommodate the strength so this
increasing density has increased cities
like singapore to design
vertically integrated developments that
consist of hospitals
supermarkets public transportation
shopping complexes restaurants parks
and other community facilities in a
single building
so in this presentation i will try to
answer some important questions
on the future of high density urban
design process
as a start we can actually confidently
say that it is going to be
interdisciplinary
and it will be informed by the recent
developments in science and technology
first we'll actually talk about how
science can help
complexity science is the study of
complex systems
there is no agreed upon definition of
what a complex system is
but it does have some distinct
properties uh a complex systems
uh consists of individual components
that actually interacts with each other
to create a collective behavior that is
greater than the sum of its paths
it is it is dynamic it is unpredictable
it is non-linear and it can be very
difficult to model
so but why do simple individual
components
give rise to complexity during
interaction
it is not always clear but unless you
actually understand that
uh the interaction itself has baits and
and the type of interaction that is
actually possible
can be larger than the size of the
system itself
so some examples uh of the complex
systems
of the earth's climate system uh the
natural ecosystems
uh and even uh an ant colony uh is a
complex system
now the two complex systems uh we are
gonna actually
explore are the cities and the human
society
so it is recently postulated that there
is a direct connection
between the structure and organization
of a
city to the structure and organization
of our social networks
so this the city is the people
so the subfield of complexity science
that studies the interaction between
these two complex systems humans and
built environment
is the urban complexity
so the field of urban complexity has uh
three different three important factors
that reveal the interaction between the
inhabitants and the built environment
the human mobility the co-presence of
people
and the spatial configurations of the
city
the network science is is another field
of complexity science
that allows you to represent the system
are studying
as networks with nodes uh representing
individual components
and edges representing the relationship
between them
the built environment can be represented
as a spatial network
and the human interaction in space can
be represented as a co-presence network
both human mobility and co-presence can
be considered as a dynamical process
that actually takes place on a spatial
network now there are two
important field of metrics to study
urban complexity
one is the socio-spatial network network
properties
and the statistical properties of
mobility co-presence and social network
so on the socio-spatial network
properties
we have the node properties such as the
centrality measures
that defines the importance of a node
based on a criteria
for example between a centrality says
which node in a spatial network is best
placed to allow
as many shortest path as possible
through them so if a particular location
in an integrated development say
is that you have the highest between a
centrality uh it means that it is the
best place to start
to uh reach any place in the building
with minimum travel distance
and the degree the degree of a node
defines the number of connections
you have in a social or a spatial
network and finally the clustering
coefficient
tells you how many of your friends are
actually friends with each other
in a spatial network it tells the
interconnectedness
between the node's neighbor the edge
properties like
shortest path tells you the shortest in
this pin distance between any two nodes
and overall a network can be actually
defined
uh by an average clustering coefficient
and an average
status path so this global properties
allows you to compare two different
networks
for example you can compare an
integrated development
with an area that is distributed on the
ground horizontally
with similar facilities and you can also
compare two buildings
and evaluate which fosters better
connectivity
and has optimal allocation of facilities
so we can also assign attributes
to these networks that are actually
useful for a richer evaluation
for example in node attributes of
spatial networks
we can define the size of the area does
it have benches does it have coron
we can also assign the type of location
is it a
social space is it a health facility
similarly in social network we can
actually define
gender age income level
on the edge articles of spatial network
we can denote the level of visibility
between any two nodes
um the routing distance between them um
we can also use the
mobility data um that actually derived
from location
data like gps or doodle um
and represented as an amount of traffic
that actually
takes place on the spatial network so
similarly
in in actually in a co-presence network
we can give the
amount of time two people spend together
how many
and the number of times they have spent
together
so next in the statistical properties
we have two important metrics first is
the scaling laws
and the second is the probability
distribution now uh the scaling laws
actually reveal
the relationship between two or more
parameters it actually shows how one
parameter
scales with the change in another
parameter so these parameters are
actually based on
real-world data for example the graph on
the left here
shows the how the crime rate
the gdp the income and patents in
360 u.s cities scales
with the increase in population both the
axis
here actually in logarithmic scales it
shows that
for every percentage increase in
population
we have a 15 increase in gdp
income and patterns but at the same time
we also have
the same amount of increase in the crime
rate
so similarly for every percentage
increase in population
we also have a 15 increase in number of
social connection
that is formed in a city now any
uh complex adaptive systems uh can
actually die
the rise and fall of many companies can
actually be attributed
to its failure to not innovate
exponentially uh to keep up with this
growth
so similarly the life and growth of a
city depends on its ability to be a
facilitator for uh social interaction
and and the best way to make sure
is to design our cities and this built
environment to maximize
the chances of social interactions
so another statistical property is the
is the probability distribution
so the data from human mobility
which is the displacement in space
can be aggregated and represent
represented in
in probability distribution for example
this graph reveals the probability
of each order of displacement in space
as you can see the long travel distances
are less probable to occur while shorter
distances are the most probable
now besides pointing this obvious fact
um
the probability distributions can be
actually very powerful the the shape
of this distribution of displacement can
actually reveal
a correct characteristic features of a
particular building
a location or even a city so similarly
in a co-presence network the duration of
co-presence
between all paths of people in a network
can be represented as probability
distribution
all co-presence events in a particular
location can be
uh aggregated as probably distribution
so hence each location can actually
reveal uh reveal its ability
uh to facilitate social interactions
so how do we make use of these metrics
in urban design um now the first
the socio spatial network properties uh
allows us to define uh
features of a location uh define
characteristic features of a location
for example
by actually having a defined social
metric
connectivity metric and space use and
the scaling laws actually allow us to
predict several
socio-economic attributes of a city for
example how much infrastructure
is required if for a particular order of
increase in population
and finally the the probability
distribution that we just saw
for example for mobility in a building
or a city
can be used to make very accurate
agent-based models
and it also can help us find optimal
allocations of facilities
so we have so far seen how
science can actually help us with
in-form design uh now we will actually
see how
recent advancements in engineering and
technology can actually help us
understand
the the signs of urban complexity so the
sensors
are a collection of sensors connected
form the so-called internet of things um
which is actually
which is a key to actually studying
complex systems uh
that act like cities that actually
requires large scale collection of data
so at each step of this process uh
machine learning uh can be used to learn
uh predict
and optimize uh this system uh for
example uh
at the sensor level machine learning can
be used to detect
any anomaly in the sensor data
or the health of the sensor itself and
it can be used to assign
adaptive sampling rate to actually
optimize
energy consumption of the devices and at
the collective level
the machine learning can be used to
optimize a sensor fusion
of the different sensor data and finally
the big data that we collected can be
actually used to track
several human activities uh for example
like uh is is a human is a person
walking uh running
or the under transportation mode and it
can also actually
uh under track uh the social behavior of
people
now uh these in turn are uh can be used
to expand
um the already knowledge uh current
knowledge we have and actually inform
the signs of urban complexity uh if if
we leverage this right
uh it can also be used uh to make
informed urban design
now uh some examples of uh how different
sensor can be used uh to track
human activities are actually shown here
for example bluetooth can be used for
localization and tracking and a
bluetooth or a wi-fi
or a radio frequency identification
device
can actually detect um
uh uh when two people has been actually
co-present together
and uh barometers are actually uh very
generally used
uh to track vertical mobility and
accelerometer signals
uh can actually be used to detect body
movements for example
a person is sitting running or actually
standing
now so to conclude the subfield of
the complexity signs that we have seen
so far the deals with the cities uh is
the so-called
urban complexity um uh it tried to uh
tries to actually understand um the
human behavior
uh and this and the built environment uh
and the interplay between them and
the network science uh has another
subfield of complexity science
allows us to actually build a network
representation
uh of this human society and build
environment
so this socio-spatial network and their
statistical properties
allows us to understand mobility
co-presence and the special
configuration
so this in turn we can actually use that
to actually make very informed decisions
on how to design future high-density
livable cities
we've also seen the reason what are the
reason advancements in technologies
and how we can actually help us to
collect data that also improves
uh how we understand the signs of urban
complexity
so and these advancements they are not
allow uh
uh they are just to be applied at city
scale uh to build better cities
but we can also better build better
microcosms of cities
uh like the integrated developments
um so thank you uh now i will hand it
over to street
to explain our future works and
application
thank you ajay um
so that was a kind of a prelude to what
um what opportunities this new field of
study provides us with
so acknowledging the adaptive potential
of complexity science
for future cities planning complex
system studies has been recognized as a
key research
track under the ministry of national
development's
cities of tomorrow r d program here in
singapore
as part of a larger study sotd is
currently working in close collaboration
with the urban redevelopment authority
the center for livable cities
and housing development board on a pilot
study
at kampong admiralty to test the new
scientific methods and tools
for understanding the urban networks for
planning future cities
so the project will explore the vertical
integrated networks
within the build space in its vertical
distribution
and its relationship with the larger
urban fabric
the methods will analyze the spatial
networks for their
interactions for their structure the
centrality measures
the degree distributions the
connectivity at urban scale
in addition to integrating actual user
data
to generate co-presence networks social
spatial performance of the urban
networks
and the active space use of design
spaces
so finally what do we hope to contribute
or achieve out of this exploration
an evidence-based multi-disciplinary
integrated design approach
to analyze existing developments
for their performance and to effectively
guide future developments
for better urban integration and to
establish an effective complexity
science based applicable design approach
to plan future cities that are
sustainable
resilient adaptive responsive and most
importantly
livable environments thank you
thank you sri and ajay for introducing
us to spatial network analysis
it's interesting to understand how this
can be used
as a tool in the design community to
understand how we are currently
designing spaces and how to inform us
better for future projects
so right now we move to the panel
discussion and the q a segment
uh before we start the q a segment i'd
like to mention that during the webinar
we pulled two questions uh the first one
being how critical would
interdisciplinary collaboration
be for future design of cities for which
a significant majority of you of those
who voted said that it's very
significant
and the second question being
should future designers uh be an
architect
seek to gain multi-disciplinary skills
or would the better solution be
to have an interdisciplinary team of
scientists architects and other
professionals
on board which would be more ideal
in this case a majority of you
around 60 percent who of those who voted
have
said that it depends on the complexity
of projects which is a very nuanced take
on
what we are also trying to talk about
and the methodology
so um i'd just like to point out that
we do welcome all your questions but
given the time constraint
all the questions may not get answered
during the session
and we do apologize for that however we
will be sharing an email with the link
for the recording
and the speaker's responses to your
queries so stay tuned for that
so perhaps i can start the q a session
with a question of mine for both the
speakers
what are some of the advantages and
disadvantages of spatial network
analysis
that your present your experience with
the computational tools has shown you
oh so ajay you want to go first sure
so there is no inherent advantage or
disadvantage
uh in this patient work analysis um it
actually depends on the context
uh but one thing we can say is that we
have to be careful
um how we use certain metrics that are
actually available in network science
and when we actually bring it to special
network analysis
we have to make sure what is relevant
and what is not
and and try not to actually make very
broad conclusions
and another thing is that the spatial
network analysis
should always be actually supported by
available data
generated by actually tracking human
activities
thank you um i think from uh for me
the key um aspect of this whole process
is how do you
uh bridge the gap of applying what
network science
provides us an opportunity with towards
um
actually designing spaces right how do
you bridge that gap like you know there
is potential for this
but you need to know how to apply them
in real world design
right so um what we need to be careful
is that some of these measures uh what
they
kind of come out with as part of the
analysis um
cannot be taken um in a very generic way
right you need to kind of assess
what do they really imply and what are
you exactly trying to find out
right a simple example is that maybe a
certain network tells you oh this is
going to be the shortest part and this
is going to have a lot of flow of
movements right
um and i might think oh if it passes
through some of these key landscape
spaces that means my space will be very
well used
uh but it may not necessarily be that
direct relation right
it could be that there are a lot of
people who are moving through that space
but
that may also deter people from using it
right so there is
there is something which we need to be
very careful about uh is
interpreting this data which we are able
to extract
um and making sure that we uh provide
ample
uh weightages right to whether it's the
spatial quality whether it's
uh connectivity whether it's visual
access there might be so many factors
which influence the space use so uh for
me as
a designer i would be very careful in
how do i extract this data
to make sure i embed it in space and see
how it uh
how it gives me cues on designing spaces
for future
yeah that's a very interesting take
um we have a question from the audience
this is for
ajay uh could you please elaborate on
the definition of social connectivity
and is it based on the degree of social
interactions
yeah so the the social network actually
can be constructed
uh based on um based on different uh
elements for example you can use
facebook
twitter uh the who you message
uh but in this particular context uh
that we actually uh
looked at in this presentation will be
we are we are talking about co-presence
network
which is also a form of social network
is when two people
have actually come together and been and
shared a common space
so if they are sharing a common space
will be these people will be the nodes
and the kind of the scenes they are
co-present will be
forming an edge with each other now this
is what we call as the social connection
and
the question is is it based on the
degree of social interactions
yes it is for example we can actually
assign weights
uh to these edges for example how many
number of times
have they been together and we can also
assign another weight called duration
which is how much time they have
actually spent with each other
and this can also be a temporal edge
which means
it only happens at that instant or we
can also assign
we can also aggregate these results and
say for a particular
period of time for example over a day
these many times they have met this is
the amount of time they have spent thank
you
so we have another question for both the
speakers
how do these methods differ from what
architects and researchers did in the
past
um okay so uh let me go first i think um
for me personally it's about trying to
explore
um something which has uh which is not
necessarily embedded in space
like because complexity science or this
whole field of urban complexity
um is looking at extracting certain
performance or parameters or certain
ways of
understanding networks and
being able to apply it into the the
realm of planning
right um and that has not yet been very
successfully translated
while there have been many studies which
researchers are still doing
um and architects are exploring um there
is still
very limited application so um
for me that would be the key part where
you're able to
leverage on new technologies new
possibilities
um and more importantly be able to
use real data which can be more accurate
uh
towards understanding the spatial
performance um because in the past the
architects have always relied on
uh you know surveys visual observations
which there is always a
level of um you know error margins or
inaccuracies
uh which comes in um so you have to kind
of
use a very large set of data to be able
to come out with some
some kind of validity right of your
result
however i think with this new technology
even if we have a small data set right
as long as we we are able to relate it
with that particular space and we are
able to relate it with the network
uh it can give us a more conclusive
evidence of
what the patterns are or what kind of
what kind of results could be derived
after it i think
that brings a very uh important aspect
into this whole study
yeah so so i cannot actually speak for
architects
but as an engineer before complex
systems
uh there was this idea called a
reductionistic
reductionist approach towards actually
studying systems
we actually study individual components
but as as the the turn of this 17th
century we are actually seeing
a lot of research that has been done on
complex systems
so we actually give more weight to the
interactions
and how they all come together than we
actually give
to the individual components so that is
something
that has actually changed and should
actually have an impact
on future designs
thank you for that uh we have uh
a couple more questions uh okay so this
is another question for both of you
uh any interesting find so far from this
research that is different from your
previous design experience
or technical experience um
okay again um maybe i'll just go uh
first
um as i said we are still in a very
preliminary stage
and we are not at a position to share a
lot of this data because it's still
um in in various stages of
uh evaluation um but one interesting
aspect when we were looking at this was
like
um when i looked at something which is
uh
uh connectivity from say a visual
perspective like you look at those
spaces
from a visual connectivity perspective
and then you look at the same
set of spaces from its physical
connectivity right the results were
quite interesting um
i mean the way uh sometimes you feel
that the spaces which are most
physically connected right
are not necessarily the most visually
connected um
and often the visually connected space
may not
be designed for a high social use you
know it might be
designed for a limited access for a more
uh you know restricted space use so that
kind of gave
a very um interesting insight into the
way
these spaces are designed in a building
right and
the question which i started off with
was whether
uh you know how when we design spaces
why is it that some spaces perform well
while some spaces kind of perform below
expectations right
so maybe there is this uh interesting
way of looking at things like
maybe a space with high visual
connectivity with
also is in the path of high physical
connectivity
might become more effective as a social
space
um as compared to something which is
less visually connected
right so um again at the same time as i
mentioned we have to be very careful not
to come up with a generic
outcome of this but relating i mean uh
relating it to a specific
project or a specific development it
kind of gives us
a good gauge to evaluate the different
spaces you know from
space use primarily space use with
respect to the way people move through
them
so um i mean that seems to be some some
of these key insights
uh there are many more but as i said uh
we are still in the process of
understanding these results
and it will be very premature for us to
come up with some
um statements because uh there are many
components attached to each of these
right
so i will kind of keep it at that yeah
so so i do not actually have any
previous design experience
uh but uh what we can we're not
actually liberty to actually share more
of the results but what we can say is
that
uh some initial results that we have
from spatial network analysis
uh is actually affirms uh some of the
uh validates some of the design
intuitions of architects
yeah yeah thank you
so i guess i could um sort of relate
your answers to a question of my own
which would be
that 2020 with the pandemic has shown us
the need
the dire need for good access to open
public spaces
so how do you envision uh the future of
you know high density focused urban
design and planning
with uh spatial network analysis and
mobility based solutions
um i would say like you know uh
more importantly um as i initially
mentioned
in increasingly right space is going to
become a very very precious commodity
right in uh in singapore specifically
where
land is really very scarce and there is
this increasing
impact on um you know using natural
or open systems for more built
environment right so there is going to
be this shift
from uh trying to conserve and preserve
the natural ecosystems and
trying to make the existing built
systems more effective or more
efficient right so i think this whole
idea of
spatial network analysis is good
from a to from this perspective that it
addresses the spatial
uh uh the spatial configurations but it
also
touches upon the social aspect of it
that means
you know as ajay mentioned for cities to
work and to be successful
it is very important to build spaces
that are socially interactive right that
that can initiate more social
interactions so for us to know what kind
of spaces will work best as social
interactions right
or what kind of spaces will uh
discourage
uh more social interaction so if we can
kind of
narrow down those parameters right what
are the key influences
is it distance is it the spatial
uh is it the positioning you know
whether it should be on which level
that kind of uh dictates whether you
would interact in that space or not
whether you would go to that space or
not
so all these could be understood by just
uh being able to break down
the way people move in the spaces right
so it's an interesting
um possibility which opens up um
and if we are able to uh successfully
leverage
on the rich insights which it can
provide
and we are able to translate them into
qualitative
parameters right to designing future
spaces
um i think this whole question which i
started with about
whether the design space i'm i'm i'm
designing is going to be
effective you know is it going to be
integrated you know it won't become a
chance
it would become an intent right i will
design with a clear
intent to know that it is going to
perform right i won't leave it to chance
i think that is where
it becomes important because we won't
have the luxury to leave it to chance
anymore
so speaking of well-designed spaces this
questions both of you
are any spaces in singapore in
particular that
you really appreciate
i think there's one picture which i
already showed which personally is
something i really like uh going even
though it is not really close to my
house it's marina barrage
i mean the fact that something which is
as simple as just
a set of um you know they're just
nothing but just pumps
you know um and how something which is
as
engineered and as mechanical as that
could
translate into an actively
integrated public open space you know
that tells you the
opportunity every project provides you
with it's just a matter of being able to
tap into the right measures parameters
to make them work successfully so uh
personally i keep always that as
a very interesting um example you know
when uh something which you don't
anticipate
to become so powerful can become a
powerful image
yeah i mean that's that's my personal
favorite of course
uh ajay has i may have his own personal
favorites
i actually like the entire campus of ntu
which i think is actually designed very
well
a lot of green spaces with a lot of
spaces
yeah and also to do with landscape
singapore and you know the concept of
density
so there are various different benefits
of high-density cities you know
including environmental social economic
aesthetic as well
as many designers and planners know so
do some of these needs sometimes compete
with each other
uh how should planners and designers
deal with these competing needs and how
do these computational tools become
violent
um i think i can i can address the part
about
whether they compete or not um i think
at some point one needs to kind of be
very clear
uh what kind of spaces are going to
prioritize what kind of benefits
right um so in terms of
moving forward i would say uh the ground
level networks right which are uh
going to be extremely critical to um
to provide the ecosystem services right
the sense like you need to prioritize
ecology you need to provide prioritize
the green blue infrastructure
at the ground level so uh that means
that
potentially um the the other
uh benefits which we are going to
achieve could be
uh tapped in on the elevated network
right
so maybe every elevated space which we
design needs to make sure that
they perform well socially you know um
that means you are kind of
um making sure that people are using
those spaces
uh it's being leveraged on well right
while the ground level
gets freed up uh to make sure that the
ecological systems
are kept in check and balance right so
for me i think
that is where um it will become critical
in future
and that's why understanding the social
performance of these spaces
becomes important as a designer
yeah so the the parameters actually
mentioned over here environmental
social economic and aesthetic all of
these parameters are actually very
important
so from technical point uh standpoint
what i what i see is uh is an
optimization problem
uh so before we actually optimize we
need to understand
how these parameters are related to each
other for example
this killing loss can actually say
what happens if you increase the gauge
garbage cans in this inner city how does
it affect um
things like that we need to understand
um how these parameters are first relate
to each other
um and we can actually uh implement
optimization procedures to actually
to make actually informed designs
thank you thank you sri and ajay and
with that
we've come to the end of our session i
hope you've all gained some interesting
insights from the presentations
and before we leave we would appreciate
it if you could take some time
to share your feedback on the session
through a quick survey
by scanning the qr code that's going to
come up on the left of your page
a link to the survey can also be found
in the zoom chat
uh please note that the survey awards
one cpd point to sila members
if you would also like to find out more
about programs that the national design
center has lined up for october
under the theme of next gen scan the qr
code that you see on the right
i'd like to thank our speaker sri and
ajay for taking the time to present to
us today
we'd also like to thank sujb and the
professors leading the research
professor thomas schrofer associate
professor roland buffane
associate professor and associate
professor samson helen
we'd also like to mention our gratitude
to the urban redevelopment authority
the center for livable cities the
housing development
board and the ministry for national
development i'd also like to mention my
thanks
to design singapore council and the
national design center
and our working team who helped make
today's presentation possible
felicia gerald zed and janine from
design singapore and daniel from sctd
thank you once again for spending your
tuesday afternoon with us
and we hope to see you all at the future
events goodbye
thank you thank you thank you everybody
thank you